22 rue de la clef des champs.
C'est bon pour l'adresse.
Qu'est-ce que ça donne dans ma ville ?
Risque inondation : faible.
Risque séisme : nul.
Ah ?
En revanche, je vis dans une zone sensible à la sécheresse.
En consultant ce site et en y entrant son adresse,
chacun peut obtenir une évaluation
des risques naturels à l'endroit où il vit.
En plus, en consultant cette plateforme on trouve plein de bons conseils
pour protéger son habitation quand on vit dans ce genre de zones.
On en parle dans l'atelier.
Bon, pour le moment, je suis épargné.
Enfin, ça va peut être pas durer, car le réchauffement climatique
peut très vite changer la donne.
En France, selon la Caisse centrale de réassurance,
plus de 95% des communes ont déjà été touchées
par une catastrophe naturelle.
Pour une grande partie des Français, le danger est donc bien réel.
Le réchauffement climatique augmente tout particulièrement
la fréquence et l'intensité des épisodes de sécheresses et d'inondations.
Deux événements qui peuvent être dévastateurs pour les habitations.
A propos des inondations : 17 millions de Français
sont exposés de manière plus ou moins dangereuse à ce risque.
C'est 1 Français sur 4.
Ça arrive presque chaque année en automne, ou en hiver.
Des crues spectaculaires provoquent des dégâts matériels impressionnants,
faisant de nombreuses victimes.
Même si les prévisionnistes de Météo France parviennent à les prévoir.
Il est souvent très difficile d'évaluer l'intensité de la catastrophe,
l'heure
et le lieu précis où la crue va se produire.
On parle alors de crues rapides.
Tenez, dans la nuit du
14 au 15 octobre 2018,
le département de l'Aude est le théâtre d'une de ces crues.
Les météorologues l'ont vu venir,
mais trop tard pour prévenir la population.
En 6h seulement, sous les effets de fortes précipitations,
trois affluents de l'Aude sortent de leur lit.
Puis c'est au tour du fleuve.
À Trèbes, près de Carcassonne, l'eau monte à 7,60m
au dessus de son niveau moyen en seulement 8h.
Le bilan est dramatique 15 personnes perdent la vie
et 257 communes sont reconnues en état de catastrophe naturelle.
Les dégâts avoisinent 250 millionsd'euros.
En 2020, c'est l'arrière pays niçois qui est dévasté.
Cette fois encore, de très fortes pluies associées à de violents orages
provoquent en quelques heures de terribles inondations
dans la vallée de la Vésubie et de la Roya.
Une alerte vigilance avait bien été déclenchée dans tout le département,
mais les prévisionnistes n'ont pas eu le temps d'évaluer l'intensité de l'épisode.
Là encore, des dégâts matériels considérables et de nombreuses victimes.
A l'origine de ces catastrophes, il y a ce que l'on appelle
les épisodes méditerranéens, amplifiés par le réchauffement climatique.
Ces événements sont liés à des remontées d'air chaud,
humide et instable en provenance de la Méditerranée.
Ils peuvent générer des orages violents,
parfois stationnaires, venant du sud ouest.
Ils se produisent souvent en automne.
C'est le moment où la mer est la plus chaude,
ce qui favorise une forte évaporation.
Ce phénomène se produit de plus en plus dans le sud de la France,
au niveau de l'arc méditerranéen, du Languedoc à la région PACA.
Depuis 60 ans, la fréquence des orages a augmenté de 20%.
Ils sont extrêmement violents.
Il peut tomber en 24h plus de 600mm d'eau.
C'est l'équivalent de ce qu'il tombe à Paris en un an.
Mais pourquoi provoquent-ils de telles inondations ?
En quelques heures seulement ?
En temps normal,
une partie de l'eau de pluie s'infiltre dans le sol,
le reste ruisselle en surface
et s'écoule vers les cours d'eau
jusqu'au fleuve qui se jette dans la mer.
Ici, la Méditerranée.
Quand les pluies sont trop violentes,
les cours d'eau ne parviennent plus à évacuer ces nouveaux apports.
Le niveau monte, la rivière finit par sortir
de son lit et atteint les zones urbanisées.
L'eau embarque tout sur son passage, obstruant les ponts.
Le niveau monte alors de plus belle jusqu'à ce que les ouvrages cèdent.
Ce phénomène est amplifié par la bétonisation des sols
sur lesquels l'eau va ruisseler encore plus.
Il est donc important de connaître les bons réflexes à adopter
si vous êtes exposés à un risque de crue rapide.
Si l'eau doit monter, commencez, avant qu'elle ne soit là
par couper le gaz, le chauffage et l'électricité.
La montée des eaux entraîne souvent un mauvais fonctionnement des installations,
ce qui peut entraîner un risque d'explosion et d'électrocution.
Pour empêcher au maximum cette eau de pénétrer chez vous,
si vous en avez le temps, fermez toutes les entrées d'eau,
y compris les aérations, ne vous inquiétez pas,
vous ne risquez pas de vous asphyxier.
Pour boucher les dessous de portes et les portails,
vous pouvez utiliser des sacs ou des barrières anti-inondation
qu'on appelle des batardeaux.
Ils sont en vente dans les quincailleries
et dans les magasins de bricolage.
Fermez les poubelles et mettez les dans un placard
pour éviter qu'elles flottent.
Placez également en hauteur les produits toxiques type
détergents, peintures, produits d'entretien.
Ça évite la pollution.
Le site gouvernement.fr vous conseille également
de ne pas sortir de chez vous en cas de violentes inondations.
Vous êtes davantage en sécurité à l'intérieur,
sauf consignes contraires.
Ne vous engagez donc pas sur une route inondée, à pied ou en voiture.
30cm d'eau suffisent à soulever et à emporter un véhicule.
Si votre maison comporte deux niveaux, ou plus, réfugiez vous à l'étage
dans une pièce équipée d'une fenêtre avec le volet ouvert,
s'il s'agit d'un volet électrique.
On ne se réfugie pas dans un grenier sans ouverture,
les secours ne pourraient pas vous évacuer.
Enfin, tenez compte de toutes les instructions données
par les pouvoirs publics.
Informez-vous auprès des médias, des pompiers, de la sécurité civile
ou en consultant le site vigicrues.gouv.fr.
Si on vous demande finalement de quitter votre habitation,
il n'y a pas de question à se poser.
Faites-le, c'est pour votre sécurité.
Même si l'eau n'est pas encore arrivée.
On vient de le dire,
les crues rapides touchent principalement le sud de la France.
Mais il existe un autre type d'inondations
que l'on appelle les crues lentes.
L'une des plus célèbres s'est produite à Paris en 1910.
Cette année là, la Seine connaît un débordement historique.
À son pic, elle est mesurée à 8,62m
au niveau du pont d'Austerlitz.
Cet épisode va durer 35 jours.
Comme leur nom l'indique,
les crues lentes sont beaucoup plus étalées dans le temps.
Elles se produisent après la répétition d'épisodes pluvieux
sur une période suffisamment longue.
Dans les grands bassins fluviaux comme la Seine, la Loire ou le Rhône.
La propagation de l'onde de crue peut s'étaler sur plusieurs jours,
voire plusieurs semaines.
En général,
ces épisodes pluvieux n'atteignent pas
l'intensité de ceux qui s'abattent sur le sud de la France.
Mais les plus interminables provoquent la saturation en eau des sols.
Ils ne parviennent plus à l'absorber et à partir d'un certain seuil.
L'eau, qui ne peut plus s'infiltrer,
ruisselle directement sur le sol vers les cours d'eau.
Lorsque ces crues sont durables et importantes,
des inondations de grande ampleur
peuvent survenir dans les zones urbanisées
car les eaux vont s'étaler dans de vastes plaines.
Elles provoquent alors d'importants dégâts.
Paris et sa région ne sont pas les seules zones susceptibles
d'être touchées en France.
La Garonne et le Rhône sont aussi sous haute surveillance.
À cause des grandes marées
pour la première
et de fortes dépressions pour le second.
L'eau peut remonter dans l'estuaire et élever le niveau du fleuve.
Une chance.
Ces inondations,
qui se produisent principalement en automne et en hiver,
sont plus faciles à anticiper que les crues rapides.
Si vous êtes confrontés à un tel risque,
pensez à aménager une zone de refuge chez vous,
à l'étage, avec de quoi tenir deux ou trois jours.
Prévoyez
des couvertures,
mais aussi un stock de nourriture, des conserves,
un petit réchaud, des bouteilles d'eau,
car en cas d'inondation, le réseau est souvent coupé,
tout comme l'électricité.
Prévoyez donc aussi des lampes de secours,
une radio avec des piles pour suivre les instructions
car il vous sera impossible de recharger votre smartphone.
On ne peut pas vous appeler et vous ne pouvez appeler personne.
Et n'évacuez votre domicile que si on vous le demande.
Les inondations ne sont pas la seule menace qui pèse sur nos habitations.
Les sécheresses, de plus en plus fréquentes à cause du réchauffement
climatique, provoquent également de gros dégâts.
En France, l'été 2022 a été particulièrement étouffant.
La température moyenne a grimpé de 2,3 degrés
au-dessus des normales de saison, ce qui place l'été 2022
au deuxième rang des étés les plus chauds
depuis le début des mesures en 1900.
Juste après 2003.
Le mois de juillet 2022 a été le mois le plus sec
jamais enregistré depuis 1960 en France.
On a relevé qu'un seul jour de pluie qui n'a apporté que 5mm d'eau,
ce qui correspond à un déficit de 90%.
À Toulouse, par exemple, il est tombé seulement qu'un demi millimètre
de pluie contre 40 mm en temps normal.
Résultat la quasi totalité du pays, 93 départements
sur 96, a été placée en alerte sécheresse et 95 ont été soumis
à des mesures de restriction de l'eau et de l'irrigation.
Du jamais vu.
Les scientifiques en sont sûrs
ces épisodes de canicule et de sécheresse vont devenir plus fréquents
et ils risquent de provoquer
de plus en plus de dégâts sur nos habitations.
Allez, je retourne sur mon site de diagnostic.
Qu'est-ce que ça donne ?
Ah ben voilà, ça se confirme, c'est ce que je craignais.
En région parisienne,
nos maisons sont particulièrement sensibles aux effets de la sécheresse.
Elle fragilise les fondations.
Et le résultat, c'est l'apparition
de ceci.
De vilaines fissures !
Vous avez peut être déjà observé ce phénomène chez vous.
Ça commence généralement par une lézarde qui passe inaperçue.
Avant de s'étendre tout le long des murs,
que ce soit à l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur.
Aujourd'hui, on estime à environ 10 millions,
le nombre de maisons individuelles
qui seraient exposées au risque de fissure,
soit plus de la moitié des maisons en France.
Mais pourquoi nos habitations se lézardent-elles
sous l'effet de la sécheresse ?
Celle-ci agit directement sur certains sols,
plus particulièrement sur les sols argileux.
On en trouve beaucoup en région parisienne et en Occitanie.
Dans les grands bassins sédimentaires.
L'argile est une roche sédimentaire très sensible à l'eau.
Lorsqu'il pleut en automne et en hiver,
elle gonfle comme une éponge en absorbant l'eau.
Mais lorsqu'il fait chaud et sec en été,
cette roche se rétracte et devient cassante.
Or, quand elle gonfle ou se rétracte,
les fondations suivent le mouvement
et les murs au dessus font la même chose.
Mais comme ce mouvement n'est pas rectiligne ni homogène
et que les murs ne sont pas élastiques, eh bien ils se fissurent.
C'est ce cycle, retrait/gonflement des argiles pendant l'année,
beaucoup plus important pendant les années de sécheresse
qui endommage les fondations des maisons
et qui entraîne des lézardes puis de larges fissures.
Dans le sud ouest, le phénomène est si important que certains entrepreneurs
du bâtiment creusent désormais des fondations
beaucoup plus profondément dans le sol
afin de trouver un taux d'humidité suffisant
qui ne bouge pas au fil des saisons.
Alors, que faire pour éviter le phénomène ?
Quand la maison est déjà construite,
D'abord, supprimer les arbres qui se trouvent à proximité de l'habitation.
Leur réseau racinaire qui s'étend suffit
à faire varier le taux d'humidité du sol au niveau des fondations,
si les arbres sont trop proches.
Il faut aussi entretenir
régulièrement les gouttières et le système de drainage
afin d'éviter que l'eau ne stagne.
Durant les périodes de sécheresse prolongée.
Il est également recommandé d'arroser régulièrement en surface.
À condition bien sûr,
que vous ne soyez pas sous le coup d'une mesure de rationnement.
Cet arrosage permet de limiter les risques d'affaissement.
Pour permettre à l'eau de humidifier l'argile en profondeur,
il faut arroser le sol au moins deux fois par semaine,
idéalement près des fondations.
Enfin, qui dit sécheresse, dit risque de feux de forêt.
Ils sont de plus en plus ravageurs sur notre territoire.
Durant l'été 2022, 62000 hectares ont été parcourus par les flammes.
En France métropolitaine,
la forêt couvre 30% du territoire.
Chaque année, on compte en moyenne 4000 départs de feu.
La moitié sud du pays est la plus touchée.
Mais aujourd'hui, certaines régions du nord ne sont plus épargnées.
Ce fut le cas de la Bretagne en août 2022.
Le feu y a dévasté 400 hectares dans la forêt de Brocéliande.
Cette situation est dramatique pour la flore et pour la faune,
mais elle peut aussi l'être pour votre habitation.
Si vous êtes situé à proximité d'une forêt ou d'un maquis,
même si une route vous sépare des arbres,
le feu peut la traverser et atteindre votre maison.
En France, on a donc établi des règles strictes afin d'éviter le pire.
Si vous habitez à moins de 200m d'une forêt,
la loi vous oblige à élaguer les arbres
et à débroussailler à 50m à la ronde.
Le non-respect de cette obligation
peut entraîner une contravention pouvant
atteindre 1500€.
Le principe du débroussaillage
est de réduire la quantité de végétation
autour de votre habitation,
mais aussi d'espacer les arbres
pour qu'ils ne se touchent pas.
De cette manière, le feu est moins nourri et il a plus de mal à se propager.
Attention,
ces travaux doivent être effectués
en dehors des périodes sèches.
Ces mesures limitent les risques,
mais elles ne vous mettent pas totalement à l'abri.
Il y a donc des conduites à tenir au cas où
un feu de forêt menacerait votre habitation.
S'il n'a pas encore atteint le périmètre de votre propriété,
ne fuyez pas.
Alertez au plus vite les secours en composant le 18 ou le 112.
Ensuite, ouvrez le portail de votre terrain pour leur faciliter l'accès
et profitez-en, si vous le pouvez, pour arroser les murs de votre habitation.
Fermez les volets, la trappe de tirage de la cheminée,
les fenêtres, les bouches d'aération et de ventilation.
Placez également des linges mouillés aux bas des portes
et préparez aussi des linges humides à appliquer sur votre nez
pour vous protéger des fumées.
Enfin, évacuer les lieux
uniquement si les sapeurs pompiers
vous en donne l'ordre.
Il se peut en effet que les routes d'accès à votre maison
soient prises par les flammes.
Vous risqueriez alors d'être pris au piège.
Voilà, j'espère que ces consignes sont claires.
N'hésitez pas à revisionner la vidéo pour bien vous les mettre en tête.
Et puis si ça vous a plu, vous connaissez la chanson.
Vous likez ou vous vous abonnez si vous ne faites pas déjà
partie de cette belle communauté d'Épicurieuses et d'Épicurieux.
Et moi, je vais vérifier mes gouttières.